Are you are you sleeping? Are you sleeping with Destiny? >> Why
is Why am I obligated to tell you anything about my sex? >> You
don't have to tell me. But like that's a different relationship,
right? >> You dumb Discord freak. >> Friday night.
Have you been drinking? >> I don't want to. >> All right,
that's all I had to say. Thank you for having me.
>> And then there's the [music] the deeds barb person as
well
that like freaks out over the Destiny stuff. I've now learned
about two of the IRL friends Destiny has
that he said aren't connected to the online space at all. One
of them is this Deeds Barb person who's like totally insane,
like actually
mentally broken. And the other one is Impath Chan. And they're
both just obs like obsessed super fans. Well, maybe not Impath
Chan. This person's like an obsessed super fan. It's like really
funny. This person Destiny was constantly saying is like their
IRL friend who it's their IRL friend who's not connected to these
spaces. She's been chatting in this for a long time and her her
logs are [__] nuts. Like they're totally nuts,
dude.
And he he every time he was like, "Oh, I'm I'm like hanging out
with people offline now. I hang out with people." It's like just
this one person
who's turbo online.
Where the logs at? Where the logs at? Where the logs at? These
are some of her logs. Okay.
Dubbie hates immigrants because he hates brown vag. Not a good
week for us melanated queens. Chat.
Doobie would know this nuance if he ever felt the touch of a
woman, which he hasn't. Oh, hold on. I should read bottom to
top. Doobie has no balls.
Doobie has never left the house for So, he has no idea streets
need to be taken. What? Doobie would know this if he ever felt
the touch of I believe Dub has kids, by the way.
Tuby has never seen a live. He has never walked on the street.
Is Dan's mom hot? Destiny, my mom thinks you're cute. I'm keeping
a close eye on her horny ass.
This is his IRL friend, by the way. This is the IRL friend. The
people he hangs out with IRL. Okay, let's see.
Okay, but you have to bail me out if Ice gets me. Destiny. Destiny,
my love for you is permanent until tomorrow.
Okay, for me, I also need cuddles in addition to CPR, Destiny,
so it varies from person to person. You lied about loving my
mom. My borders are open for your mom. Tehe
my little Cuban sandwich. Destiny. DGL.
This is the This is the normie IRL friend. Just to be clear,
Destiny, talk to us. We are thirst.
Ly love you. Maybe Jesse, you have no idea what a chokeold American
media has on the rest of the world. My parents would make me
watch Golden Girls in the Middle East to ensure I had good conversational
English even for an event for an eventual migration. Lau Desty,
let me hammer your face, please.
>> Why was I not invited to Chatter of the Year interviews,
Destiny? Yes. When I was little, the white girls had Belle, Cinderella,
Rapunzel, Ariel, and I only had Jasmine, and Pocahontas, Destiny.
Feels bad, man. But they were the best
Destiny, do not cut your beautiful brown mommy out.
Oh my god, you went trick-or-treating, Destiny. Did the moms
try to lure you with candy?
I'm just whose deeds? This is Destiny's IRL friend that he was
talking about. He was discussing stuff with his IRL friends.
He's spending a lot of time talking with IRL friends. He's one
of the IRL friends apparently. Let's see here. Oh, this is a
good one. I am with Destiny in the washroom. Sh. Destiny, come
to the washroom right now. Destiny, please sneak into frame like
a little gnome. Destiny, please take the stage. I'm sleepy. Destiny,
shut the [__] up and take the stage. I am in bed
with hot chalky wait awaiting. K. You can't be a wig at this
old age. Destiny, you've been warned. Sorry. I I just thought
it was really funny that this was apparently the IRL friend he
had that he was like hanging out with when he said, "I'm not
I'm not hanging out with online people anymore." This was the
IRL friend. Read the one below. Wait, I don't I can't do all
of it. It's a lot. Okay. I just thought it was funny. I heard
about this and it was just funny to me. Hold on. Where Where
are we looking here?
Yes. All billionaires except Taylor Swift, Rihanna, and Selena
Gomez. Destiny spare the diva girlies.
Is do obligated to admit she's suing Destiny because she would
prefer not to get a real job ever? Destiny, tell him how much
you adore beautiful
Destiny, could you ask him if he hates Nubian as much? Why does
he his frog avatar have a black mouth area when it's supposed
to be pink? He went out of his way to make it black.
That's another doobie post, by the way.
holy deeds in the waiting room.
You think so?
Deeds Barb. Is this actually Oh, it is. Oh, it's the Deeds bar.
You want to talk to this person? You want to come on stream?
I mean, >> I guess it's kind of >> Deeds Barb in
the in the stream. What's up, Deeds Barb?
>> Please don't be Kathy. Please don't be
>> Yes. Okay. >> First of all, I don't do this very
often. I'm very IRL.
>> Uh-huh. Yeah, you're very IRL. I got it. >> for
sure. >> Okay. I heard you had a lot to say about me. What's
that about?
Uh, I pulled up some of your logs. Can you join the presentation?
>> I saw a little bit of it. Someone sent it to me. So,
is your actual problem my logs or is it that I called you out
for calling Z and air a bunch of names? >> You went to
>> Wait, what names did I call them? Uh, thank you for
the donation, whoever that was. Awesome sauce. Thank you for
the >> roof of a cyber truck. The roof of a cybert truck.
And you and you constantly run cover for Kyle Writtenhouse, Ryal
Kittenhouse, and tell him that it's okay to use thumbnails that
are degrading to women. What's that about? >> I run cover.
What do you mean run cover? What's the cover I'm running?
>> You keep saying that you disavow it, but you still keep
giving him work. What's that about? >> What do you mean
by give him work? >> Why don't you tell me how he's associated
with you, and we'll talk about it. >> He clips my stuff.
>> I don't pay him. I don't get revenue from the channel.
But where does he get the vauds from? From God.
>> From a publicly accessible page that anybody can get
the VODs from. >> Yes. But you are involved in it in some
way. So that means I can go in and I can use your thumbnails.
I can use your fat ass neck.
>> No. Right.
>> I you would have you would have to give me permission
somehow. So don't be a
>> No, I don't have to give you permission. You can actually
go steal all of it. >> Why you run cover
to women? So, your actual problem is that I call that out and
racism though. >> You're just talking over me. I'm literally
telling you you could go do this right now.
>> You're not listening. You could go do all of the things
you just said you couldn't. You could just take my VODs, my thumbnails,
you could upload them
>> Yes. And you would copyright strike me. Obviously, don't
be >> Yeah. If I don't like the outcome of the channel,
if I don't like like that it's representing my views, then I
would copyright strike the channel. >> Humiliated. You
like the outcome. That's what I'm talking about.
>> Hold on. I like the outcome of By the way, your server
your server your server is filled with women who posted come
soaked pictures of themselves with destiny and me sending my
friend hearts is offensive to you. Do you know how stupid that
is? I support their choice. I love that for them. Mole power
to you girls. I don't send men my full lab on the first date.
That is my choice. Choices. Choices. Choices. I'm not jealous
of anyone. He's my IRL friend like you said. and having a bunch
of girls in your server that have posted all kinds of things
that they've done done with Destiny and then shaming me for sending
him a few heart emojis. Do you see the hypocrisy in that? And
your actual problem is that I call you explain the hypocrisy
server. Could you explain the hypocrisy to me? >> Don't
put that out. Stop demeaning. >> I'm actually interested
in the hypocrisy. Could you explain the hypocrisy to me? >> Punishing
women just because you explain the hypocrisy to me. Could you
explain the hypocrisy?
Let me explain the hypocrisy to you example. >> Are you
not going to explain the hypocrisy? An example, >> an example
of the hypocrisy.
>> An example of the hypocrisy. There's women in your server
who have in the past been open about the fact that they have
slept with Destiny and they've posted pictures about it, which
is totally fine. That is their prerogative. That is their prerogative.
But then you >> I'm mocking you for being obsessed like
an obsessed fan. Heart emojis. You're pulling up my chats of
a few heart emojis and being like, "Here's a crazy
>> They're very funny. Hold on. Let me pull them. I'll
pull them up right now. >> They're very funny. Yeah. You
want to pull them up. You don't want to pull up the You don't
want to pull up the the the videos of Riyle Kitten House distorting
every That's your actual problem. That's what I came into the
>> If you got those thumbnails, I'll pull them up for you
as well. >> Yeah, we can look at the fact we can look at
the fact
that this isn't really
just go through like a point at a time like maybe one. >> Let
me give you an example. Let me give you an example of a crazed
fan. A crazed fan is someone who stalks. This doesn't seem like
what you came in say >> is someone who posts on Twitter
about how she come she came 15 times and he he came two times
or whatever the [__] she >> So that was someone
you dated. So you love crazy. >> Wait, are you are you
sleeping? Are you sleeping with Destiny?
>> Why is why am I obligated to tell you anything about
my sex life? >> You don't have to tell me. But like that's
a different relationship, right?
>> No [__] obligation have no obligation to
tell you about their sex life. So you can use that to exploit
them. Zoe and Stacy on your in your in your server. >> 4
a.m. in Miami right now, right? >> Do Zoe and Stacy on
your server agree with me? 4 a.m. in Miami right now.
>> And you're from talking about this right now and watch
all the racism play out? Are they going to cover for you or are
they going to come on? >> Do they have the balls? Do they
have >> Did you really just come on to like verbal diarrhea
like this? Why don't you try and like make a point and argue
it down? Like I thought that's a bad idea. >> you might
get a dunk that way as well. going on and be awesome. >> Could
you be Could you enunciate a bit >> No, I'm >> You
said Why did you come on just a verbal diarrhea or did you come
on to like actually talk something through?
>> I think I made my point that you're at me for bringing
up the fact that you're a misogynist and you you don't want to
address that. You want to bring up my logs like the that you
are like the that you are. >> So you want to address my
misogyny with the comments on
Z and Aerodite.
What is the justification for posting a picture of Z and comparing
her nose to the roof of a Cybert truck? Walk me through your
playbyplay.
>> You didn't post it. So, we're going to play these verbal
ver verbal games and I don't mind it. >> I just want you
to be specific about what you're alleging I did. >> I told
it up on stream on stream. You put it on stream and you slowly
with your cursor went over her >> could I could you send
me that image so I could pull it up again? >> No, I don't
have all your logs, sweetheart. I don't have all your logs. stalking
you like you're stalking me.
>> Literally just asking somebody to send me the image
so I can pull it up >> just for reference. >> Do
it. Let's discuss
>> Oh, here's a here's an example of an aerodyite thumbnail.
Did I cover Aerodite on Tim Pool? >> Are you asking me?
I don't watch your >> I'm asking my chat. I don't remember
covering this. >> Okay, good. Good. Ask your chat. Ask
uh Stacia and Zoe who were heirling me in the chat yesterday
and watched all the racism play out and didn't say anything and
now they're gonna run cover for YouTube, I'm sure. >> Also,
racism. What was the racism?
>> The racism is the minute I was in chat and I don't swirling
around me trying to [clears throat] get
>> two people
out for calling my brown, they took something out of context
from my chats with Destiny and uh they kept saying, "Oh, is her
brown? Is she pressed that Dubie doesn't want her? Um, so all
that I can take out of context
real quick. >> Destiny, tell him how much you adore beautiful
brown/black.
It's not [snorts] that one, right? There's another one. >> Yes,
I was talking I was talking to Dubbie. I was talking about Dubbie.
Obviously, you're missing the context of me speaking to a streamer
while he's streaming something.
Is it clocking for you yet? >> You were speaking to Destiny
or Dubbie?
>> To Destiny.
Who was talking to Dubbie? I I tagged him and said ask Dubie
why he hates brown because that was that is what he was banned
out of. >> There's something here about your brown or something
right now. I don't know what was said in the discord. I missed
it. I saw people get timed out but I missed it whatever was said
in the discord. You remember what you said about
specifically?
>> So before before pulling up someone's logs and you know
someone in your in your Discord server has been timed out because
of him. You didn't do the work of finding out why they were timed
out because of me. You somehow have all my >> I totally
don't care about my Discord. Uh, somebody sent me this I imager
album in DMs. >> You don't seem to care about anything,
Juice Docker. That's your problem. That's your problem. >> You
certainly don't care about Discord at all. You're right. >> Yeah.
You care about the ice raids. You care about the ice raids, but
you don't care about people calling me Muslim and Indian and
brown on your Discord server. >> Yeah. I I think one of
those is a bit more serious than the other. No, >> the
ice are more serious than calling me
>> Yeah, they are. But stuff doesn't happen in a vacuum.
Do you understand why the ice raids are happening? It's because
of the other authorization of people like >> Trump presidency.
I think it's
>> the ice raids are happening. >> Okay, you can
pretend. You can pretend you don't understand that racism and
all this stuff is part of a continuum. >> No, I think you're
right. Trump won the election cuz people make jokes about you
on Discord. That's so true.
>> Yes. Okay, good. It's clocking for you a little bit.
Um, so don't pull up my logs again. I will come in and I will
I will hold you accountable. I'm not like the girls. Some of
the girls held account of the girls on their pull up but most
of them are extremely stupid and that's not my problem. That's
not my stupidity on your server. >> This is the other image
we needed to pull up. This is not funny. We disavow this image.
It's not even a good comparison. Like look at that's it doesn't
it's not the same at all. >> The chin doesn't work here.
The chin totally throws this out of whack. It cannot make any
sense. Whoever made that's [__] idiot. >> So
I now have I've like obviously disavowed this. Okay.
>> Oh, thank you for that. Thank you for disavowing it
after I drug you through the mud. Thank you.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. >> Okay, that's all I
had to say. Enjoy. I will, if you want to find me, I'll still
be in chat sending my friend, my performance performance. Okay,
this is >> By the way, what's your impression of IRL totally
prove that you're like IRL friend? Are you stupid? Are you literally
stupid? People in IRL can't >> Wait, why do why do you
think Destiny presented you as his IRL friend?
>> What is Yeah, that means that we chat in real life.
That's what he means. That means we don't have like Skizo freakouts
on Discord. >> Did you guys meet in real life or did you
meet via the internet first? Where did you meet first? >> I
met him through Jubilee.
Okay. >> Okay. So, you met him through content. So, you
knew he was a content creator. >> Correct. like the the
expression like what he was trying to communicate when he talks
about his real life friends is these people aren't connected
to the online world right I'm not dumb I'm not dumb as some of
the people on your server that's all he was trying to communicate
and I think he was successful as you can see and how I'm displaying
right now that's all he meant that I'm not hanging out with dumb
>> Friday night have you been drinking I don't want to
>> All right that's all I had to say thank you for having
me
>> good times
I just dude I just wanted to ask like she sits in the discord
reading the one channel where they mock her and she can't talk
in that channel or she couldn't talk in that channel and she
DMs the people who mock her to like have arguments with them.
I don't know.
Uh
is it clocking for me? I don't know,
I don't know.
We try to keep this one around.
How did you get her? She just joined. I don't know how she joined.
What's up? >> I shed good luck. I don't think that's someone
with a very long lifespan, to be
I saw someone who's built to last around here. I I I like try
to ignore this stuff and then people keep bringing it up, bro.
I I try to ignore it. Okay,
>> that photo on screen sweeps for Z's dimensions. No,
we're not doing more Z hatred right now. Okay, I said to pull
this up to She explicitly referenced these two points. We had
to disavow them.
This is gross. Ri, no more of this. No more of this.
No more of this. Okay.
No more of this. Kilo. Kilo. No more of this.
It's got to stop. Okay. It's got to stop.
It's all got to stop. Okay. Deeds is on Food Chops. Let's go.
Oh my goodness. We get to do both. I think Food Chops reacted
to that stream from earlier tonight. Like she reacted to the
Deeds call-in. So, I'm very down for
Food shops. Food shops. Food shops. >> I'm calling them
for it just mainly because um like they hear another like voice
with the same tonality and then they're like, "Oh my god, it
sounds like Naso Paradise." That's what you have a higher voice.
>> Yeah. I don't >> Yeah, we I think we have some
similar cadences. I agree with that. I think my style is a little
different. I think I'm a bit more um >> It's the mouth
sounds >> sarcastic and abrasive. Like I I use the word
a lot. I use the word a lot as you saw in the justical server
uh in the justical stream and I >> I mean to be fair Naserai
I'm sure Naser would also use pretty abrasive words. No
>> uh she doesn't use as frequently as I just dry mouth
sounds. >> Okay. So so one is like 40% the other is
>> Yeah. Or maybe I am her and I've decided to present
this alt personality where I say the word bit and put a lot more.
I think she uses
>> yo spruce will private huff. Thank you guys for the
gifted subs. Four subs for >> word a lot more and I think
she I've heard her use your mom your mama jokes or your mom jokes.
>> Yeah. I kind of meme that in chat but I don't really
speak that. It doesn't sound natural with my voice. Um so yeah
that's all I had to say. And also I wanted to some of the girls
on there are really me for calling them out. I think I think
if you feel violated you should bring lawsuits. Absolutely. And
I will support people if they want to bring those. That's not
a big deal to me. But that doesn't give you a free pass to be
>> these mouth sounds are >> like, oh, racism is
happening. I don't see it because I was violated once. Are you
crazy? Like the statute of limitations on on that is done, honey.
Like if you see racism and around you, you're supposed to call
it out. If you don't want to call it out, then I'm within my
rights to call you a
automatically confer women with my >> I haven't I haven't
seen this. Where where is the racism? Does somebody want to send
me a screenshot of the racism that was done? >> Opinion.
That's not >> I mean you said yeah you you said something
you said something about like
um I don't know like if someone feels like they have been violated
enough they'll come to it. Like I I'll let you know that this
lawsuit sure like I agree with you. It's just that this lawsuit,
you know, there's a reason why nobody else wants to join this
case, right? Out of the all the alleged hundreds and thousands
of women that Steven has repeatedly brutalized. You know, >> nobody
ever said that.
>> Um, yeah. I I don't know why someone would or would
not join. Someone can feel violated and not join a lawsuit, and
I think that's okay. >> Sure. Sure. I agree with that.
Do you know the the the the Do you follow the court files? I
do follow >> I do. Yes. But um no, I get summaries of it
and I get the gist of them. I don't feel like I need to go through
it line by line >> from uh just curious from who?
>> Sorry, could you repeat that? I didn't hear that last
part. >> Where do you get the summary? >> We all
know who they both get their summaries from. >> I I have
seen them on your stream some of them and I have seen Steen talk
about it. So actually that's how I heard of your channel because
you popped up for me adjacent to and also Stephen mentioned you
as one of like I said before one of his not not the only but
one of his soldiers. So I always like that and also I kind of
did get intrigued by your other um by your expedition 33
um debates.
>> Yeah, that's great. >> Yeah. Um one other thing
I wanted to say. Wait, did I say everything I wanted to say?
because I don't want to like endlessly loop about this because
these people are only capable of looping on one or two things
whereas I I feel like I'm a much more nuanced person. Um the
other thing I a couple of things I found funny. Okay. Uh they've
>> Wait, that's totally unfair. That's totally unfair.
I loop on hundreds of things. What the I get obsessed with hundreds
of things. I get obsessed with so many things. That's so unfair.
>> On that server that my English is too good, so I can't
possibly be Indian. So, English is my third or fourth language.
You lose count after the first two. Um, but again,
>> no, no, literally nobody loses count of the number of
languages they speak. That's the most thing I've ever heard in
my entire life. >> A little bit of projection of low IQ
on me. There seems to be a lot of that going on.
One language. >> Hold on. I I don't think they actually
think that you're actually
>> Commodore Chop. Thank you for the five gifted. Let's
go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> But I actually am Indian. you are.
>> Absolutely. Yes. Why would I lie about that? I am South
Asian. I'm Indian. I'm very happy with it. I'm very proud of
it. Um, someone posted, "Oh, she's Indian." And one of the innocent
girls on there, I I'm willing to believe this wasn't a dog whistle,
but the first comment was, "Oh, what does that mean?" Because
there's been this meme that like uh DG is filled with Indians,
right? Um, yeah, it is. It What if it's filled with Indians?
is filled with Indians like me who are much more well spoken
than a lot of these like mumbling fools who've been doing this
for years. So what about
>> So true. >> Based based queen I have I have no
objections my queen. >> Yeah. So English is my third or
fourth language and I'm sorry I can speak it better than Mr.
Quimman who was a bump. >> This guy is so right now sitting
here muted mic. No response. He's got no response at all. Totally
obliterated.
Absolutely obliterate. No response.
>> Barb one, >> humbling fool with me. Called me
drunk. If I were drunk, let's say I were tipsy or drunk, which
there's nothing wrong with, right? >> He called me drunk.
He called me drunk. He called me drunk. I wasn't drunk. But even
if I was, wouldn't they be that bad? >> If I were drunk
and I still I still kicked that guy's ass. So, who's winning
here? I I mean I mean like I I think I think it's just because
you're a yapper and I think that's why he said that you were
drunk, which to be fair, you are a yapper, but I think that you
would probably be screaming at them if you were drunk probably.
Maybe. I don't >> Um yeah, I guess. I don't know. I I don't
think I'd be screaming at them. I don't think they deserve my
screams or whatever. Um it's pretty easy to >> It actually
wasn't that she was drunk or sorry, it wasn't that she was like
yapping. It was that she decided she was going to hop on the
stream at 4:00 a.m. her time on a Friday night.
It was 4 a.m. She was like, "Oh, I have to hop on this JCO stream
and yell at these
>> Sorry. That's that's
>> with an even tone. It doesn't take a very talented person
to decimate them. I >> maybe that's why they're so scared
to see because he actually has verbal acuity and they do not
like the way Justin was dodging my questions like, "Did I post
it? Did I post it?" What? He put it on.
I wasn't dodging. I literally told her what I did. I'm like,
the whole purpose here is to say, hey, you're getting like really
worked up. Just say what you actually know. Right. I I said,
did I did I post it somewhere? No, I put it on stream, right?
>> Dream. But he wanted he wanted me to commit to um stupid
extraneous details. What a talent for extraneous details that
duo has. That's their only talent because they don't have any
that's why they want to that's why they have to do all the >> wrong
misogyny. Another key core talent that we have that we put on
display during this, you know, the conversation in question.
>> They can't do the actual political stuff because they
don't have the verbal acuity and they have to project it on DG
on Steven and all that [__] and we have to bear with
them as a result of that. What idiots?
>> like they >> that's all I have to say. >> Yeah.
Like uh they are
I I think I think they have to play like these definition games
in order to like avoid accountability. I think um like for example
they think that um
they try to narrow down a lot of things so then they can avoid
being called like harassers or counselors or something of that
sort right um I think the reason that could happen didn't happen
in this conversation but the reason that could happen is because
usually when you're coming at me and saying like I'm so much
worse than Destiny I do all these evil things and I'm like well
do I do I is that true
I noticed. [__] I'm not. >> Yeah. I mean, I
like to I like to play these games, too. >> I do find it
very funny that we have to go really far. We have to run away
from me or Quimman even to actually run into
right? Unless you want to accuse me of being a misogynist, in
which case, listen, the evidence is piled up. I don't think I
can really win that argument anymore. I agree. I understand.
I lost that argument. Okay? I'm a misogynist. I did put the fat
audit thumbnail on stream. I put the Z picture on stream. I'm
a misogynist. It's it. She won. She won. >> That one is
that >> I I hope you guys understand that after many years
of saying that I'm a perfect feminist, that I I'm not a misogynist
at all, that I've lost I've lost completely. Okay,
it's Rob. It's over. It's over. And she she did it. At >> some
point in the past, Steven has had um a chatter where um
>> uh that person in particular um was was named uh can't
close Vim and he would const he is a huge tanky huge tanky and
all he would talk about is um bombing Ukraine and Ukrainians.
Um, so when Ukrainian whenever Ukrainian was on stream, um,
actually not what that guy was known for, by the way. He wasn't
he was a tanky, but he wasn't known for being a tanky. He became
a tanky in like the last two months that he was around in that
community, maybe 6 months top. >> Uh, like he would just
say like, "Oh my god, I want to grape her. I want to grape her.
I want to grape her so bad." You know, or something like that.
Um, >> okay. And
now like like he would just say like, "Oh my god, I want a grapeer.
I want a grapeer. I want a grapeer so bad." You know, or something.
>> That's also not true. >> That is also false.
I don't think he, as far as I know, he didn't say anything like
that. As far as I know, it was just the one joke where he said,
"Listen,
this stupid
women need like re-education." And then he said, "I hope she
suffers a special romantic operation or some [__]
like that." It was wild. Okay. But it was just the one time.
>> Oh my god. Um
>> And
now like whenever people reference Ken Close Vim, like especially
in the um anti-fan communities, um they are referring specifically
to like the comments about Ukrainian Anna and Yeah. It is basically
a dog whistle like condoning her like getting essentially.
But like >> sounds sounds kind of sick to me. Sounds very
sick to me. >> Sure. Yeah. I I mean like one way you need
to think of these guys is that um you know they're kind of like
gropers, you know, like they don't actually believe DG is full
of >> Last Friday night. That's it. Epic song.
Epic. Last Friday night. night. Yeah, we
but I forgot.
>> Hey, don't hit. If you can hear me, please sing.
completely totally entirely disavow that entire video that I
just played of like Indians. Nor do they actually think >> of
course I know that >> anything like that. But they will
use plausible deniability and humor and edgy humor as a way to
obuscate their real ideas as their real goals. Like like they'll
they'll say they'll say
>> Yeah. Uh they'll say like I want Steven to die. Okay,
just joking. He right. Like that's it. And they'll never ever
to die thing. That's fine. That's not that's a very generic like
we all say I'll kill you and stuff in in everyday >> Yeah.
I was just giving an example. I was just That's it. Yeah. It's
just an >> Yeah. But but the what did I want to >> incredibly
lazy two-dimensional analysis. Incredibly lazy analysis.
Yeah. So the the ice comparison I made, they're being so obtuse,
right? these two white men who aren't really under attack by
ICE. >> How did it go to ICE? Like >> let me explain
that in case in case people were confused. So I'm not making
a onetoone comparison between me being called all kinds of names
in chat with ICE obviously. But we do understand that that racists
in MAGA didn't have an epiphany one day that they are racist,
right? They slowly were exposed to content that otherizes people.
Somalian people in particular in this case uh like Nick Shirley's
content and then at a certain point ICE got pulled in and now
ICE raids are happening and that poor woman was shot in the face
because she was a little bit uh combative. So the the >> and
that somehow relates to the content we do on stream where we've
been [laughter] dude it's so crazy how far out the lunch they
are >> idea of being
we love Nick Shirley here. This is a pro Nick Shirley stream
now apparently. >> Oh, like you're doing a onetoone comparison
when these two people are not really going to be stopped and
asked for their ID where whereas I would be because I am brown
and proudly so. Um that is >> does this not understand
who got shot first?
Hey, what was the color of skin of the first that got shot? Can
you tell >> Is that is ridiculous. So yeah, they can laugh
and clown and have the plausible deniability that they want.
Um
>> to me, sorry, sorry, sorry. Keep on keep on saying >> Magab,
why are you behind? Sorry.
>> What the [__] [laughter] Sorry. Go ahead.
Sorry. >> Yeah. No. So, so they can have the plausible
deniability that they want. They can uh do the groper adjacent
memes and pretend to be liberal. Like apparently I I didn't go
into their stupid ass hug box today, but they've been talking
they've been talking about a bunch of legal stuff, liberal legal
stuff on there because they care so much. Oh, I'm sure they do.
They care so much. Um that the first thing I got in chat
I just don't understand. Does she think we need to do like some
virtue signaling about politics to be racist for groers? Is that
what she thinks? Does she think groers sit around in like group
chats or discords and they're like, "Oh man, it's really rough
with seeing what we're seeing with ICE." That's really disturbing
actually. Does she thinkers do that? >> Was like, "Oh,
are you Indian? You're DG or Indian? You're Muslim?" Um, I totally
believe it. I believe them. I believe they really care about
me. I can feel the care, you know. Um, but yes, I'm glad that
we have such positive
>> Why Why are you Why are you resisting Why are you resisting
um Why are you resisting their care? Like why are you pushing
them away?
>> Why am I [laughter] Why am I pushing them away? Like
they clearly care about you, you know? >> Yeah. I would
rather I would rather be around I'm not even kidding. I would
rather be around Nick Fuentes who would tell me to my face that
I am not good genetic stock which is a joke. Um, but yeah, he
he could tell me that to my >> Wait, it's a joke when he
says it or it's a joke that you're saying >> compared to
these people who'd be like, "We are liberals, but we do all this
crap like in these very closed, not even very closed environments."
And the women say nothing about it. >> Oh, hold on. Private
Huff, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it, dude. Appreciate
it. >> And give us free passes. And that's where we're
cool. Like, if they want to do that [__]
>> Private Huff and then Wait, did I get two private huff
notifications? What the [__] happened
I'm confused. Thank you very much for the two subs, guys. Appreciate
it. >> Do that, you know, like it's it's No, it's not fooling
anyone. Um, there's a few Uncle Toms on there who only bring
up their race to protect to protect the white people. Be like,
"We're not racist. I'm actually black." Well, good for you. When
have you brought up your black outside of this context? Probably
>> Wait, hold on. Sorry. I'm pulling it back a little bit.
I missed I missed something. Was it Commodore Trump? Well, I
didn't I didn't add the hour when Commodore Trump gave the five,
but we we have another hour
to protect to protect the white people be like, "We're not racist.
I'm actually black." Well, good for you. When have you brought
up your black outside of this context? Probably never >> because
you're scared that they'll otherize you as well. Um, so yeah,
they can do what they want. I'm not too bothered. But yeah, this
is the last time I'll address it because they had a couple of
problems with me which um, yeah, I just wanted to address very
quickly. And I didn't want to go on to that that fat neck stream.
Not today, neck. Not today. Canles.
>> He uh you know, I think he has a crush on you.
>> Um probably >> I'm enjoying the how much with
how much they're covering like every single log and you know
it's >> I know. I'm really >> Okay. Okay. That one
I cannot suffer. That one I can't even lean to ironically. Are
you going to actually say this when Desi's had like 15 different
Imager albums of my Discord up on his stream? Are we really gonna
pretend that I'm the person covering every log right now? Are
we really gonna do that? Are we really gonna do that? Okay, let's
go banan forb on who's covering Discord logs or DG logs, whatever
the [__] more often. Okay, these guys bring up my
Discord logs. Not even mine. Discord logs from my Discord more
often than I cover them ever. It's wild stalking someone's Facebook
page. Okay, just don't let them just don't let them farm too
much content out of you,
Yeah. No, let them have a little fun with uh whatever they can
because it only it only doubles down on the idea that that they're
picking on someone because they decided to not be as submissive
like some of the women on there, which I you know that's that
>> I think we were mostly laughing at this person cuz they
make totally insane claims and then never once back them up.
That's more why people I think in the Discord have a problem
with her. She just alleges a bunch of and never remotely backs
anything up and then just does the verbal diarrhea or texting
diarrhea thing refusing to respond.
I think that's why people make fun of her. Uh, also her incredibly
cringe logs to Destiny. But >> that's their choice. If
they have to feel if they have to be that way just to fit in
with those dudes, then fine. Um, I made a different choice. >> Yeah.
I I think it's extremely disappointing. Um because there are
some at least one woman on there last night we had a >> conver
that that are like um obviously SA survivors um like real SA
survivors and stuff and I thought that they would know better
um than to like be a part of that specific community because
you know I'm not one to judge like how any SA survivor like reacts
to things. Um but like the way >> but not this one. I I
think I think that >> I I hate to say it. Do they think
like the vibe I want for my Discord is like a shelter for battered
women? Like it's just a women's shelter. That's not what my Discord's
about. There happen to be some people who were wrong by Destiny.
You shared their material without their consent. There happened
to be people like that in my Discord. That's not what the Discord
is about. That the stream the Discord was made way before those
people came in. Those people are welcome. But this is not a women's
shelter. I don't know what the these people are coping about
that this is like a women's shelter free of misogyny forever.
Now
Dayan does have admin. So there there's some element of like
we do respect women because there's literally someone who will
bring the hammer down if you don't. But it is largely against
our No, it's not largely against our will. Hold on. It's um
we do our best. Okay. We do our best to be respectful. you are
becoming the thing that you hate the most like you are becoming
like the essentially like yeah that's what I think >> um
I wouldn't be that like but a lot of people do this a lot of
people acquies or they buckle down or they enter the communities
or they they bully they get bullied and then they adopt the views
of the bully that is very very common um but like it's it's silly
to do both things like you can do that if you want but when I'm
when I'm >> yeah some people just haven't been groomed
enough. Okay, that's it.
>> Okay. Well, um I'm going to go because I have to sleep.
I actually had a very long flight today. I have been flying for
Jubilee.
Um I'm glad it's out now >> Oh my god. Can Can you link
your appearance in Jubilee to me? >> Um no. I don't want
to make it too easy for people to find me, but I mean I >> This
person desperately wants to
She keeps dropping. She keeps intentionally dropping breadcrumbs
about her identity because she wants to get harassed. Just for
so everybody can make it clear, right? She wants to be harassed.
Destiny wants her to be harassed. That is the goal of this person
appearing on streams and doing content, right? Destiny wants
her to be harassed. They want her to be found. They're going
to keep dropping little breadcrumbs of what she's doing, like
what she's involved in until she gets harassed by somebody. Why?
Because then they can go, "Oh, look. She interacted with JTO's
Discord and now SHE'S SHE'S GOT SHE GOT DOCKS IN HER. OH MY GOD.
BUT THEY'RE JUST INTENT. She just keeps intentionally dropping
breadcrumbs of her identity. I don't know why. I can't prevent
that. By the way, if she had nothing to do with my Discord at
all, it would happen. If she kept dropping breadcrumbs of her
identity on food shop stream while being connected to Destiny,
she would get harassed. I don't I don't know. Like I cannot be
blamed for this. If Destiny hasn't explained to her what to keep
private when he knows that people track his personal life and
will go after people, dude, I it's wild to me. Okay,
but no one cares. Uh I I don't know if anyone cares. I certainly
don't care. I don't think anybody around my community cares,
but I'm just saying that she has very very very clearly continued
to drop little breadcrumbs about her identity trying to get her
harassed.
Trying to get herself harassed. I don't know if it's like intentional
on her part or if she just hasn't been informed. It's very >> Kind
of I kind of did a bit of a [__] up. I mean, not
really a [__] I'm not really ashamed of who I am.
So, I said the Jubilee thing just to be honest, but if they want
to find
judge I mean I mean Well, okay. Can I watch it privately then?
Like, can you send it to me in private or is that not allowed
either?
>> Uh, let me let me think about it. Let me think about
it. I want to make >> I won't reveal it on stream. I I
won't I won't reveal it on stream. Okay. >> Okay, cool.
I'll [snorts] send it to you. Well, it will be spectacular. So,
I will I will speak to you. Bye. One last thing. One last thing.
Magabus, my editor here, thinks that you're based.
>> Okay. Well, thank you. Thank you, sir.
>> so so cool. Okay, that was fun. That was a fun little
slide out.